it looks like we have a favorable vote
the moderna vaccine
on track for emergency use authorization
following the fda advisory panel's
overwhelming endorsement
in a 20-0 vote the advisors agreed the
benefits of moderna's vaccine
are greater than its risks the evidence
that has
been studied in great detail
on this vaccine is highly outweighs
any of the issues that we've seen once
emergency use is granted
and the centers for disease control
signs off
more than 50 million doses for health
care workers and care home residents
will be distributed
vajra's vaccine follows last week's
pfizer approval
it comes as coveted infections and
deaths continue to spike
due to the november thanksgiving holiday
there are fears those numbers will climb
further with the christmas and new year
holidays
just days away millions of americans
still
fear the vaccines were developed too
quickly
and are unsafe that's why u.s vice
president mike pence and his
wife will get vaccinated on camera on
friday
to boost public confidence the challenge
to contain the virus will be daunting
for america's next president joe biden
it's time to stand up take back our
democracy
but as he prepares to take on this
challenge
other headlines linger we have great
confidence in our son
biden and his wife dr jill biden
appeared on the late show with stephen
colbert to defend their son
hunter he confirmed last week
prosecutors are investigating
his tax affairs but the president-elect
says he's not worried i'm not concerned
about
any accusations but made against him
it's used to get to me
i think it's kind of foul play but look
it is what it is
and he's a grown man the accusation his
son
profited from his time as vice president
is a headline joe biden can't seem to
shake
as he prepares to take the oval office
and confront
the global pandemic kimberly hellcat al
jazeera
washington